stade communal à l'arrêt depuis un mois
mais dit l entraîneur du club de
football amateur
une situation difficile à gérer c'est
déjà compliqué travailler dans ces
conditions donc
donc voila et puis là le fait de
recouper encore le championnat s'arrête
pas au niveau des organismes
on va reprendre là en plein hiver avec
le froid donc va falloir une certaine
préparation depuis un mois mehdi
communique avec ses joueurs par internet
pour garder le contact depuis le début
de l'année le club qui compte 4 134
licenciés a perdu de l'argent déjà par
rapport à l'ancien confinement que l'on
a eu en mars bien on a vu que quand même
des grosses pertes financières les
résultats que l'on a eu fin juin qui
était déjà moins quatorze mille en bas
de page a encore cette année si on remet
ça je veux dire ça va être compliqué
pour survivre quoi
outre les pertes financières le club
s'inquiète aussi pour le nombre de
licenciés en baisse soleil à des parents
qui sont en difficulté et qui paye la
licence en deux fois alors bon
avec le confinement et il commence pas à
payer c'est ça la difficulté est moins
d'adhérents pourrait entraîner une
baisse de la subvention votée chaque
année c'est le conseil municipal qui
décidera je pense pas je sais pas c'est
le conseil municipal qui lit ses
dirigeants entraîneurs joueurs tous
attendent maintenant la reprise avec
impatience là j'attends qu'on puisse
reprendre au moins les entraînements sur
le mois de décembre parce que sur ce
qu'on entend il pourrait faire reprendre
les mineurs seulement je vois pas quelle
différence à faire courir des petits et
des grands
on est en extérieur en plus le chef de
l'état s'exprimera mardi prochain les
petits clubs seront alors fixés sur leur
sort